So let's take a look at the channel economics.
In other words, how are we going to make money?
So let's take a look at a direct sales example.
You have a sales force and you're selling directly to the end consumer.
So let's assume that the list price of your product is $100.
So one of the first questions in thinking about how to come up with this $100 list price
is to understand how much did it actually cost me to manufacture a product.
Now, in the web, it might be the cost my engineers.
But in a physical product, it might be the costed bill of materials coming out of my factory.
And so let's assume for the sake of discussion that that was $33, $33 to build my product.
Next, let's take a look at the cost of my R&D, that is my engineering;
the cost of my direct sales people, maybe commissions or direct sales compensation;
and then general and administration costs, what it cost me to have leases and lunches
and free snacks, and that might be another $20.
And so right now it's $53 just to keep the lights on in my building.
Now something we should consider is that no end-user pays was priced.
So let's assume that this area represents a discount from the list price, let's say 10%.
That means your revenue to your company would not be $100 but $90.
So wait a minute, you're getting $90 but you spent a total of $53 building the product
and keeping the lights on and that leaves right in the middle how much profit you have.
In this case, it would be $37.
So, you're selling costs were embedded here, this was the commission or direct sales costs
or whatever you were paying your direct sales people and you made $37 selling directly.